we're organizing the first ever open
source AI game Jam compete to make a
game in a weekend and use AI tools to
push the boundaries of game development
you have a weekend to make a game
following a theme which will be revealed
when the jam starts Friday to Sunday
July 7 to 9. AI tools Sim power game
developers unlocking new creative
possibilities like World Generation
ai-powered NPCs and realistic
text-to-speech especially when those
tools are open transparent and
accessible which is why in this game Jam
we require you use at least one open
source AI tool interested in
participating sign up on ichio link in
description and if you'd like to join
the community find teams or talk about
game ideas join our Discord